Welcome back everyone this is my spider-man no
way home video for the miles morales scene we'll
explain what's going on with his character in the
mcu what their plans are what they've said about
him so if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos quick shout
out to my friends at nordvpn who asked to sponsor
this video normally on my marvel episode videos i
do giveaways for disney plus memberships but some
of you might live in countries where disney plus
isn't available yet and you have to wait forever
to get new marvel phase 4 movies on streaming but
with a vpn you can actually change the location
you access content online from even if you live
outside the united states you can use a service
like nordvpn to sign up for the us or the uk
version of disney plus they even gave it a huge
shout out during spider-man far from home so don't
take my word for it you should probably download
a vpn on your phone just so that the government
can't track you while we're abroad smart she's
not wrong you can also use a vpn to stop anyone
from stooping on your browsing history and nordvpn
is currently running a holiday discount deal for
their service i'll add a link in the description
below or you can go directly to nordvpn.com/emergencyawesome
so be sure to check it
out they have a 30-day refund policy just
in case you decide that it's not for you real
quick reminder about spoilers from spider-man
no way home if you have not seen the movie yet
because we'll be talking about a lot of stuff
that happens at the end of the movie in the way
they tease miles morales character in the mcu
like live-action miles morales but after the final
battle of the statue of liberty with toby maguire
andrew garfield and the sinister six villains each
of the separate versions of spider-man sort of get
a reunion scene with their original villains
so like toby maguire has a scene with doctor
octopus where they referenced their history in
spider-man 2 the miles morales scene happens when
andrew garfield is helping electro after he's been
de-powered he's giving him a bit of a pep talk
because electro thinks he's a total douche now
without his powers and andrew garfield's trying
to remind him that hey you were a genius scientist
at oscorp before you got powers like you had some
stuff going for you and jamie foxx's electro gets
real with him saying that back during the events
of amazing spider-man 2 before he got his powers
when he was this hardcore spider-man stand for
andrew's version like he loved spider-man
that's why he wanted to meet him so badly
he thought that because he was from queens and
he spent so much time trying to help poor people
he just thought that he was going to be a black
dude underneath the mask and andrew garfield
spider-man is like oh i'm sorry max in electro's
like don't worry about it there's gotta be a
black spider-man out there somewhere talking
about the multiverse the spider-verse the mcu
just in general somewhere out there and that's
marvel and sony teasing live-action miles morales
spider-man in future movies like they'll get
to him eventually but everyone's been asking
where he's going to show up and how they'll
handle his origin story in the mcu in what
are the larger plans for introducing his character
if you remember way back in spider-man homecoming
donald glover played aaron davis the prowler miles
morales uncle and during that movie he said that
he wanted to help spider-man get rid of all the
alien weapons that vulture was dealing because
his nephew lived nearby i don't want those weapons
in this neighborhood i got a nephew who live here
that was him referencing miles morales in the mcu
but at the time like when the scene was taking
place in the timeline he was a really little kid
in a long way from getting the spider bite there
was also a deleted scene from that movie as part
of this whole thing with donald glover's character
where he actually says the name miles morales and
it's the only time miles's name has ever been said
out loud in the mcu the most direct reference
to his character a human being needs help
he just do man yeah sorry miles i'm not gonna make
it yeah i'm just stuck so in the mcu we have all
these mentions name drop scenes featuring his
character before spider-man no way home came out
on theaters just a little while ago kevin feige
and amy pascal answered some questions about him
they were asked what had happened to this version
of miles from back in spider-man homecoming did
he get snapped during avengers infinity war did
he not get snapped and did they age him up five
years closer to mcu peter parker's age because
that was everyone's big theory they just aged him
up during that five year time jump so that they
could introduce him sooner and he'd be closer in
age to tom holland spider-man like miles would be
going to high school by the time that peter parker
spider-man was in college which he's doing at the
end of spider-man no way home that's what the ged
course book is for at the end of the film so that
he can get into college just like mj and ned leads
and we'll see that happening during spider-man
4 when the events of that movie pick up but the
funny thing that kevin feige did is that when that
he was directly asked about this version of miles
morales he said you know what we've got this great
spider-man across the spider-verse animated movie
with miles coming out next year and so he just
started hyping up the animated spider-verse movies
we just got a trailer for that a couple weeks ago
i've already done a couple easter eggs videos and
breakdowns for it because there's a whole bunch of
other versions of spider-man from the spider-verse
they're introducing in so i'll post links for
those in the description below so you can re-watch
those it's gonna be awesome spider-man 2099 is
putting together another team it's going to be
crazy but i think the main reason kevin feige did
that just deflected immediately to spider-verse 2
is because he didn't want to steal any
thunder away from the animated movies
tom holland has said that he's excited
for them to introduce live-action miles
morales in the mcu and he wants his peter parker
spider-man to become a mentor to him eventually
kevin feige the sony people also just recently
confirmed that they're working on the next
spider-man movie now spider-man 4 in the story of
what will happen to tom hall and spider-man next
after this movie but then tom holland comes out
and says you know what it's not a total done deal
yet like we're still figuring that out because he
wants to get paid like robert downey jr got paid
like they'll probably make him a producer on those
new spider-man films and that's how he earns his
50 million dollars per movie but yes if you were
wondering tom holland is coming back it's just
the ink is not totally dry on his new contract yet
like they're still haggling over money right now
but the spider-man no way home ending basically
acts as a teaser for spider-man 4 it kind of
tells you what's going to be happening during
the events of that movie when it picks up
he's got himself a very tobey maguire looking
dumpy apartment mr dikovich says he still needs
that rent give me rent you'll get your rent
when you fix this damn door he's taken his
integrated suit that he had during the
final battle the combination of the iron
spider suit in the advanced suit and used
scraps from it along with new regular cloth
material to make himself the most comic book
accurate suit that he's ever worn in the mcu
this is a really good high-res picture of what
it actually looks like notice how the spider-man
symbol has changed and it's also way more comic
book accurate i'm waiting just a little bit longer
to do more spoilery videos about what's going
on with the suit what's going on with andrew
garfield toby maguire in the future movies because
they will come back for more stuff eventually
but i think the idea with this new comic book
accurate cloth friendly neighborhood spider-man
low-tech suit is that when he was with toby
maguire and andrew garfield in the movie working
with them he was inspired by their versions of
the suits and saw that they had made their own
they were cloth they didn't have any special ai
or anything like that so this suit is inspired by
their suits and when spider-man 4 picks up they'll
all be in college and if he doesn't get into mit
and he goes to college inside the new york city
area like to colombia or empire state like the
comics they'll just find an excuse for ned lee's
and mj to come back and visit new york city during
the plot of spider-man 4 so they can be in the
movie too because yes i do think that zendaya will
come back for spider-man 4 ned lee's will probably
come back too but the idea is that in that new
spider-man trilogy 4-5 and 6 that's when they'll
introduce live-action miles morales in some way
and what'll probably wind up happening just early
prediction is that they'll wait till like the end
of spider-man 4 and it'll be like a post-credits
scene because we had that venom post-credit scene
with the symbiote so clearly they want to do
some version of a symbiote saga with tom hall
and spider-man and it just feels like trying
to do symbiote saga and miles morales all in
the same movie all at the same time do all those
different origin stories it's just way too much
story for one movie so that's why they'll probably
start with the symbiote saga stuff and then slowly
roll in live-action miles morales the report
right now though is that sony wants to do spin-off
solo movies with live-action miles morales so he
wouldn't take over the main spider-man movies that
would still mostly be tom hall and spider-man with
some miles morales crossing over in them and when
they do miles morales first live-action solo movie
they'll probably just call it spider-man into the
spider-verse or some iteration of a spider-verse
title and do a legit version of the franchise in
live-action even though spider-man no way home is
already kind of a live-action spider-verse movie
tom holland said that he had to delete his
scene during the first spider-man into the
spider-verse movie he was supposed to have
a really quick cameo scene that's featured
during some of the trailers where miles is in
the subway saying wait a minute how many other
versions of spider-man are out there at one point
i was supposed to be in it yeah there was going
to be another peter parker like it was like a
scene in a train station or something and like
it was it was going to be like a like an easter
egg i was going to walk through the background
and say like hey kid or something and never
happened heartbroken um but i'm just excited for
us to introduce miles into our own universe one
day i think that's going to be really cool should
be wild should be a wild wild time can you tell
us about the spider verse honestly man i'm sick of
this spider versus right i'm the only spider-man
it's me only one there ever is and ever will greg
sorry they were also going to bring back
toby maguire and andrew garfield spider-man
for the animated spider-verse movies but at the
time back in 2018 sony said that it was too soon
clearly it is no longer too soon clearly
it is the right time because they totally
brought them back for this movie but like i
said i'll do a separate video later this week
for toby and andrew and what the plans are for
the future of those characters inside the larger
mcu and sony movies and the other funny thing that
just happened is that tom holland was saying how
he wanted to be in the new spider-man across the
spider-verse sequel movie lord and miller the
producers of the movies said please call us so it
sounds like tom holland will actually get a cameo
scene during spider-man across the spider-verse
but if you have any other big questions about
live-action mcu miles morales or what's going on
with the character or spider-verse questions just
write them in the comments below my full hawkeye
episode 6 finale video will post next remember
kingpin is back yelena belova is still a huge deal
so it is going to be awesome my video should be up
pretty early in the morning on wednesday everyone
click here for my full doctor strange 2 trailer
breakdown and easter eggs and click here for my
full spider-man no way home post credit scene
with venom thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!